common business oriented language or
COBOL is a weak verbose and flabby
language used by coat grinders to do
boring things on dinosaur mainframes it
was developed over 100 years ago in 1959
but is still in demand today in 2020
because it's the language used on many
mainframe computer systems you know
those things we call big iron usually
built by IBM to handle massive amounts
of throughput to handle things like
credit card transactions airline
ticketing and most recently the massive
spike in unemployment claims so if you
want to be a programmer in 2020 COBOL
might be your best bet it's a high-level
imperative language which means it's
very easy to learn the syntax is
extremely verbose by design because it's
self documenting and it contains over
600 reserved words for you to memorize
to take advantage of and every COBOL
program is structured with an
easy-to-follow hierarchy your program
contains many divisions which contain
many sections which contain many
paragraphs which contain many sentences
that contain your statements which of
course contain many characters when you
start writing some COBOL code you'll
notice these vertical lines in your IDE
the first six characters are your line
numbers start at zero zero zero one
hundred and increment by 100 for each
line column seven is where you identify
comments or the continuation of a
previous line if we're identifying a new
division section or paragraph we can use
columns 8 through 11 and notice how
every line ends with a period that's
what's known as readable code now
columns 12 through 72 are where you
write your actual statements the reason
you don't go beyond 72 columns is
because your code needs to fit onto a
physical punch card and it ensures your
program is responsive on mobile devices
we can define our variables in the data
division first we name the variable then
we define its data type with the picture
keyword then assign a value to it we can
then work with this data in the
procedure division we display the
variable then tell our program to stop
from there we can pile our program to a
binary run it and everything should work
perfectly and now you're qualified for a
six-figure salary maintaining the
world's most critical legacy systems
this has been COBOL in 100 seconds hit
the like button if you want to see more
short videos like this thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one oh hey there thanks for sticking
around this is the part of the video
where we go beyond 100 seconds to
learned some more advanced features of
COBOL